[Music]
so what we go astray is when we say
there is nothing else but computation
there's nothing else but thinking and so
on the the great ones knew that the
five-person seasons of which the reason
knows nothing and I think that we have
to take some uh wisdom from that and
take it seriously and then you know
that's the balance and that's the
balance
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
foreign
it is a great pleasure to be talking
with a renowned scientist mathematician
thinker philosopher actor producer
author who wears many hats and he's
actually coming to us from where uh you
know where I gotta start in a certain
sense my father was a was a math PhD you
see Berkeley and work very closely with
Jim Simons and that's how they met and
that's how the Simon's Observatory came
to be uh but we're not here we're not
here to talk about my favorite subject
which is me we're here to talk with
Edward Frankel uh Edward how are you
today up North I'm doing great Brian a
good good to be here with you and thank
you for that for this generous
introduction yes yes it's all it's all
true uh so your Legend has been known to
me for many many years so we have mutual
friends uh like Eric Weinstein and
Stefan Alexander uh and I started to
become aware of you originally back in
2015 2016 mean when I started to think
about writing a book and I came across
your wonderful book called love and math
the heart of hidden reality and it was
really shocking to me that a math book
even though I'm the son of a
mathematician that a math book could be
so fascinating and so touching and
personal so I want to do the thing
you're never ever supposed to do which
is to judge a book by its cover that's
that's verboten you're not supposed to
do that
but we're gonna do it so I want you to
explain hold up the book explain the
title The subtitle and what that
beautiful images meant to represent
well you know I I can take credit for
the title but I cannot take credits for
the cover for the cover art
uh it was really a stroke of of Genius
by the my publisher basic books
um so the cover depicts um a fragment of
the famous painting by Van Gogh
it's 39. and they chose it and I was
just like wow this is great now this was
not totally random because in the book I
do say that van Gogh was my my favorite
painter when I was a kid so I was
exposed to his art early on
I remember my mother took me to a museum
the Pushkin Museum art museum in Moscow
when I was maybe 10 or 11 years old and
I was absolutely fascinated with Van
Gogh's paintings they had a very good
collection of Impressionists in general
but somehow I was just drawn to Van Gogh
which is like standing in front of those
paintings it's just totally mesmerized
you know and so that that Affinity that
love for Van Gogh kind of continued I I
discovered other artists and so on but
it's still up there for me one of my
favorite absolute favorite artists so I
guess maybe the artist who designed the
cover for the book
read that passage or something also it's
about what is it about the story night
it's about sort of looking at the world
at the universe and appreciating its
beauty
and asking questions what what where
does this light come from uh what does
it mean what does it all mean and I
think all of us have a memory of
an experience of that nature when we
were as you know kids maybe when the air
was not as polluted okay especially For
People of Our Generation
speak for yourself up north up there
Crystal Clear down here oh really well
good for you but you know I remember the
kid we went on a on a field on a trip
you know like a hiking like you know
with this backpack but backpacking trip
was my it was my classmates I must have
been 14 or something and I remember we
were somewhere in a village in the
middle of Russia and I saw that the
night sky unbelievable it was like wow
it was just like really made an enormous
impression on me so I guess that cover
maybe communicate some of that also that
sort of the kind of spoiled innocent
sense of beauty and mystery of the
universe which I guess I I try to convey
in my book as well now the the title the
title is kind of interesting because I
people kept asking me why did you did I
choose this title loving that and and I
I didn't know when I was writing
sometimes well you're you're an author
so you know sometimes you only later
come to appreciate and understand what
you write sometimes you just try to kind
of you know people say sometimes channel
is something I don't want to go we see
it on you but it is true in my
experience that I
um re-reading the book years later
I was like I wrote this really I didn't
you know it's like I post now I can see
the meaning of it which I could not
possibly uh consciously appreciate at
the time that I was writing so you know
when people ask me after the book was
published uh what does it mean what does
the title mean I would make some kind of
jokes I would say you know
11 magic of Aladdin Coleman
um it's easier at first but then it gets
awfully complicated something like that
but then later on I kind of appreciate
what it means to me it is like it is a
new iteration on on the
um Eternal theme
that we have as humans this sort of uh
balance between
uh yin and yang masculine feminine the
Sun and Moon uh Apollo Indiana the left
brain and the right brain logical
intuition so to me love and math
represents like these two pillars of
humanity you know on which
um we we kind of which on which our life
is based and sort of our life to me is a
kind of a unfolds
in this sort of infinite spectrum
between those two polarities and in a
way uh the older I get
the more I kind of
become interested in the question of how
do we find balance between the two how
do we start how do we find in in our
personal lives but also in our life uh
as a society you know so that's what
that's what this title represents to me
and you mentioned the subtitle is is the
heart of hidden reality which is which
is uh similar in some sense to a book by
Brian Greene uh who's not been a guest
on the podcast but he assures me he will
be on someday
um so in the context of string theory so
that kind of hearkened to me this quote
by my hero uh as my listeners are
probably long suffering uh from from
hearing about but Galileo Galilei I was
actually just in his prison slash house
a couple of weeks ago in in archetree
Italy and Galileo said something
Beautiful the book of nature is written
in the language of mathematics and he
considered himself a natural philosopher
that's what we used to call physicists
and I want to call it a different
physicist mathematician Eugene vigner
who gave a lecture at New York
University in 1960 called the
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics in the Natural Sciences and
it sparked a debate that continues to
this uh to this day how could it be that
mathematical Concepts purely of the
human mind will talk about the great
debate as math invented or discovered
but for example he mentioned in the
statistical distribution of populations
which we have for voting and and all
sorts of aggregations appears the the
ratio of the circle's circumference to
its diameter what the hell is that doing
in there
um so how do you react or the sum or the
sum of inverse squares of voice to
vintages like one one plus one over four
plus one over nine plus one over sixteen
and so on yeah if you want to do it
yourself to pi squared over four right
right by squared over six over six
you're just a math man my father of
blessed memory he used to say don't ask
me to calculate a tip on a on a bill
because I'm a mathematicians are the
worst with the team you know it's the
worst it's never never try to divide the
bills no never do so what does that
quote mean to you why is math so uh
effective in physics and in the heart of
hidden reality making it illuminated I I
quote I I use this quote on page two of
my book okay so yes you're asking so
it's a great question
what does it mean well there's so many
layers to this you know
but
um our our Western Society is built on
this idea which is very powerful idea of
analyzing things and ordering things and
um actually I would I would trace it
back much earlier than Galileo to my
hero Pythagoras because it's a great
great mathematician philosopher
so he said all things known are numbers
right so there is this impulse
um to
represent things to analyze things to
put them in as part of a system and
ultimately it means actually
representing things by numbers and find
and representing the various
connections that we observe and between
things
as equations and as formulas and so on
right so so going there so then after a
while that that that that
kill that thread that theme which to me
signifies sort of the birth of Western
Civilization we're talking about 2500
years ago give or take
uh for that for a while that thread was
kind of went kind of not silent but kind
of quiet and it was picked up by in the
Renaissance and people that followed
especially Galileo and that eventually
led us to Descartes until the Industrial
Revolution and here we are you know so
um the book of nature is written in the
language of mathematics
and then he says for those who don't and
and the the letters the the in it uh
circles and triangles and geometric
figures like that and those who I'm
paraphrasing those who are not aware of
them are are bound to wander in a dark
librarian so in other words
it gives us tremendous capacity to
innovate to evolve to progress as a
species one might say you know as a
humanity is species to create all this
technological wonders and so on also
brings us a lot of grief so
you know sometimes I say
we have built so these beautiful
cathedrals but also bombs
to destroy those Cathedrals so in that
sense it's always like you know uh in in
one motion the my mathematics gives and
takes away and that's where our wisdom
needs to come forward and to help us to
discern to understand to see the
limitations of knowledge also the
dangers of
um logical reasoning around the mark who
is when it's not supported by Love by by
Connection by compassion you know and so
I think this is where we find ourselves
um so a few centuries after Galileo 2500
years after Pythagoras in a way
re-evaluating this
um words this maxims that the
instructions that they have given us
I think we have taken them maybe
sometimes a little too literally and
maybe time has come for us to show more
maturity
and more wisdom in appreciating that
mathematics is not everything it gives
us a lot it is a language of nature but
there are other aspects of nature that
are just as important does it make sense
yeah no it does and actually it seems to
me that we fit the language of nature to
the needs at hand you know for example
Galileo was very close to getting the
inverse Square law but he couldn't quite
get it he got this law of of squared
times from you know dropping things down
but then we remember he didn't even have
clocks back I mean really we're dealing
with very primitive physical entities
and if we fast forward you know 400
years uh from Galileo to Feynman Feynman
then refines the statement and says uh
calculus is the language God speaks and
you know these are very breathless
things but you know great physicists
great mathematicians but do you feel
like we find the math that we need for
the time in other words could we find
some times I hear oh string theory is
the math of the 22nd century that fell
into the 21st century
I mean here's the first thing that comes
to mind okay when you're asking this and
again there's so many layers to this
yeah I hope I hope we'll talk about that
but here's the first thing that comes to
mind is don't you find it fascinating
how people usually speak about so it
used to be it one of the ways people say
God it's things they don't know but they
don't understand and they say mysterious
that was sort of the Paradigm in the
years past but what I find more often
today is that people speak of what is
God is what they have mastered what they
have understood or what they feel they
have understood so
I have understood calculus so calculus
is God it comes from God and that's
that's the essence of things and that's
the Core Essence of that well I
understand see it Theory great this must
be the grand unified theory of
everything because I have understood it
now so what else could it be right so
I'm like don't you find it a little a
little bit strange yeah
it's like
coincidence
or not like should you be a little bit
should we have a little more humility to
say just because I've learned this
doesn't mean that I already know
everything or I'm close to knowing
everything and in fact if you look at
history
every time somebody
went out and said
we have now
mastered it this song this must be the
mess from God and that's basically all
there is they are put to shames of the
famous quote from Lord Kelvin from
around the 1900s when she said the
database of physics is basically
finished and all little problems
the Michaelson Mike Michaelson Morley
experiment about the speed of light
which of course we know led to
Einstein's relativity that's right and
radiation of the black body which led to
Quantum Mechanics okay just these two
little things you can otherwise we'll
understand everything so I am a student
of History I would like to be a student
of history and say what it shows to me
is that every time I have this impulse
and it's a very natural impulse nothing
wrong with it to say I got it I should
put I should hold myself back and I
should not allow myself this type of
hubris to to say that that's it that's
what it is
travel yes maybe it is part of the story
it is a part of some design or you know
it depends on your sensibility to what
extent you want to how friendly you are
with a mysterious certain people how
much you want to emphasize it but I
would like to I would like to believe
and cope actually that
I don't know most of the things I still
don't know and in fact why I say hope
because I think life would be boring
if in fact everything was known or we
were close to be to the point where
everything is known so no we are not
close and that's good because that means
that there is so much more to discover
there's so there's going to be so much
more joy going forward of learning more
things and saying Eureka all over again
you see right so that's the first thing
that comes to mind but on the other hand
what makes to me is an exhaustible so
sort of continuing the same line so in
other words
whereas physicists sometimes
in my opinion no criticism intended
because I come to this idea that they
are chasing this ultimate theory that
some kind of Health material is possible
and sometimes they say okay we will come
up eventually with the theory where all
the main equations can be written on a
t-shirt right it sounds like a great you
know motivator but I think
in mathematics is different so if you're
a student of mathematics and I I even
though my first love as I explained in
my book was physics I really wanted to
be a civil physicist right and study
quantum physics but uh
due to various circumstances I actually
went
um in a slightly different direction
I went to my to mathematics and then
eventually I came back and I have
collaborated from various brilliant
physicists and so I
in many ways I'm a mathematical person
but my upbringing is as a mathematician
when you study the mathematician you
never hear this from your teachers you
know from your mentors we are chasing
the final Theory no because there is no
such idea that there is a final Theory
but nice is inexhaustible it's Limitless
it's infinite so the progress in
mathematics is is infinite and eternal
and you always continue to discover new
things and so for each era for each book
if you will its own mathematics it's all
emphasis
you know uh on the particular area of
mathematics
and I wonder you know pivoting from that
uh if when I look at some of the most
you know kind of gratifying or beautiful
things in mathematics that eventually in
hindsight turn out to have applicability
in physics I can't think of anything
more kind of surprising or spectacular
than the fact that we have these you
know classical commutation relations
between position and momentum In
classical mechanics in lagrange's theory
and you know back in the 1700s and and
you take that theory and you just add in
the square root of negative one and a
little constant called H bar and you get
uh the quantum commutation related which
don't commute and so the poisson bracket
or the key point the key point is though
right so right there was the brackets
that those guys wrote they were placed
on brackets yes
but you have a certain Apparition on the
commuting quantities they're still
they're still numbers they're still or
numerical they could be functions but
well value to numbers and numbers
commute least 13 times 5 is 15 and so is
5 times 3 but uh in fact I think it's
kind of an accident what happened is
just because we use numbers like whole
numbers or rational numbers or real
numbers so much and they commute that
it's natural for us to believe that the
world is commutative and the greatest
one of the greatest uh to say uh
breakthrough or uh sort of like
uh discoveries in quantum physics was
that the world is actually
non-commutative and as a mathematician
if you are a professional mathematician
you know that most out most algebraic
structure are known commutative which
means that a b is not equal to ba
and of course I usually explain it by
saying you know if you put socks in the
phone and then shoes
it's not the same as that's right the
other way around or a a a courage before
the horse or after the course these are
two different things so that's not
committee and the point is that at the
very basic fundamental
um level our universe is non-commuted so
that was the big discovery that was a
big jump the big Insight those guys in
classical physics they still can so that
everything's commutative classical is
commutative and there but there is a
germ on unconductive already because you
know that to write down the equations in
a hamiltonian form it is useful to have
this additional structure which is
called poisson project and like you said
you know uh the you can think of passing
from classical physics to quantum
physics
quantizing personal brackets where
instead of commuting quantities you
suddenly now have non-commuting
quantities such as uh
momentum and the coordinate and this
non-commit activity is really at the
core of all the paradoxes and all this
weird and strange behavior of of uh in
the subatomic world you see so uh but
you're right that mathematicians already
in anticipated in some sense even though
they could not possibly imagine that it
could be taken this far that's where
that's where you have to appreciate
physicists you have to appreciate people
like Heisenberg
coerculine we discovered this
non-compactivity without even knowing
mathematics involved which had been
um constructed can had been uh theorized
100 years earlier but I'm talking about
this theory of matrices so matrices when
you multiply them they also don't
commute and so high things are just
driven by experimental results they're
trying to build a new Theory which would
explain them right was was and he wasn't
this famous it's not a famous story it
was an island where there was no books
no mathematicians which may actually be
a good thing
no Department chairs no departments no
committees to you know but also the
point is he actually invented matrices
yeah how cool is that so there are some
fundamental structures in mathematics
which are inevitable and which are
brought Upon Us eventually by physics
same with complex numbers by the way is
clerical negative one that you mentioned
was theorized by mathematicians uh you
know in the 16th century but then make
their appearance in mechanics still
showing your equation and other things
so I also woven into the fabric of the
universe
and my conjecture that you'll probably
laugh at is uh is what if you had all
these things uh you had uh well I mean
as we just said you know bomboli I think
it was convented the complex algebra and
the rules of it he's a contemporary of
galileos
at least Euro I mean there were several
people who talked about but he wrote it
in his book right did I do something
numbers there yeah and then Descartes
and of course Euler and all sorts of
other people got into it but um but the
but the important thing to realize they
were contemporaries with Galileo not not
with like Heisenberg so what I wonder is
you know this is my controversial
proposal for the podcast so could you
look at all the mathematical structures
that are known to exist and say let's
pick the Lang langlands program there
must be some physical instantiation of
the of that some I mean you've called it
a grand unified theory we don't have to
get into that but um but as as a little
tongue-in-cheek because I know
yeah I feel humor me what if you looked
at all the just put all the Dropbox yeah
so could you discover new physics that
we don't know about now
okay
okay so again several things that you
are you're inspiring me to think in
civil Direction so first of all I would
say my you may be maybe will be right
that this example the first example
being uh square root of negative one and
complex numbers are being theorized by
mathematicians just abstract it in order
to but not completely abstract you know
there was the reason to try to find a
corner Solutions of quartic equations
where this square roots naturally appear
um
so
then they pop up in quantum physics and
they are fundamental to quantities yeah
and then quaternions and Hamilton
um then poisson brackets and stuff like
that and so uh non-contactivity and so
on so that one might uh lead one to
speculate and to conjecture that maybe
all of that Max somehow will find its uh
a proper place in the natural world in
the world around us
May well be true I know I at the moment
I I'm inclined to think otherwise
because simply because mathematics is
just so
enormous yeah and so the there are
certain um
um there are parts of it which seem to
have no connection whatsoever but it may
well be my own limitation and my own
Prejudice you see so because immediately
what I'm starting to think
uh things like
um human space Integrations like the
space and then oh wait that's an
essential ingredient of quantum physics
already okay so it hasn't found its
place okay okay bad example so periodic
numbers so there are these counterparts
of real numbers which are called
periodic numbers which are give us a
different generalization of rational
numbers to fractions or integers I I I I
was going to say they haven't found any
uh place in my in uh physics but I just
remember that a couple of months ago I
was actually looking at some articles by
physicists who are trying to
um feed them in some models of quantum
mechanics
so the images
so I would say this is one of those
cases where I would say I don't know may
well be true but maybe not so because
you know in the end also
uh it's possible that mathematics is
just a kind of a has a certain
not necessarily A focused on the opend
to the physical reality because it is a
kind of a
activity of the mind right so in a way
one could also say that it's like a
event diagram so where you have an
overlap between the two but the two
subjects kind of like uh develop on
separate paths
[Music]
right they mean
and um that was something else I was
going to say but anyways I mean the
other thing I want to run by you because
you know we don't have that much time
but but you know I can't resist talking
about you know in in both string theory
and in uh inflationary cosmology which
is what I study experimentally uh
there's a notion of a Multiverse uh and
string theory it's typically called a
landscape where you have all these
different instantiations of vacuum
energy level and then um and we often
and then there's a Multiverse of many
universes and if you know one thing
about it typically in both scenarios
there there's a claim that there'll be
different laws of physics there'll be
different laws of physics in Multiverse
you know Universe number 65 00012 versus
65 00011 yeah whatever or in the string
landscape you know where there's an
infinite distribution of vacuum level my
question to you is
um could it be that in some of those
universes uh the laws of math are
different in other words why why should
it be that just changing the vacuum
energy density change changes the speed
of light C or Newton's capital G or the
electronic charge or fine structure why
couldn't it change the ratio of the
circumference to the diameter of a
circle why couldn't it change modus
tollens
um could you see a scenario where a
Multiverse of you know mathematical
Universe not in Max tegmark's conception
but but really that you'd have different
versions of mathematics in different
universes and and could maybe we could
use that to rule out such a such a
fantasy
well I think again I don't know but I'm
I'm inclined to think that that's not
possible
um that might makes it Universal in some
sense so that even if there are many
universes
um in fact I used to do this thing um I
would sometimes start and give talks and
I would talk about this universality of
mathematics and I said what if we meet
Aliens which I guess now has become sort
of like much more much closer to the
realm of possibilities uh what if we
meet Aliens and we start talking to them
right is it possible that they actually
have different mathematics
and I like to illustrate it with one
example where people say for instance
one one country one way that I heard
that people would articulate the
possibility that they would have
different mathematics they would say
they would be the following argument for
us mathematics for many of us Mad Max
starts with numbers with natural numbers
one two three four five why because we
see multiplicity around us you know we
have received many people we have seen
we see many trees you know we have uh
you know with strawberries there's
several strawberries several of them so
it's natural for us to count
but what if you have um
a kind of a civilization or which only
has one entity which one conscious
entity like in the movie Solaris or the
book by stanislav it's hilarious you
know where it is a planet which is
conscious and it doesn't have any any
other so there are no other solarisons
in it's in this world right so then it's
not you say okay it's not natural for
it's hilarious type intelligence which
is one which is unique
to to think in terms of numbers so they
would do different type of mathematics
so it's not even the question of
mathematics contradicting two different
mathematics
structures contradicting each other but
just sort of developing it from a
different place
and to to this and I think this is a
very interesting point where actually
one could articulate that the tool it's
possible that they would start from a
different place but they would still
meet with us and the the way I
illustrate it by saying that numbers can
be discovered
Solaris intelligence could discover
numbers through what mathematicians
called homotopic groups
so to explain this think imagine I wish
I had a my flow a flaws handy so imagine
just taking a floss and wrapping it
around your finger
okay so you can you can you can wrap the
floss Around Your Finger once twice
three times four times and so on this is
how a finger could this given flaws
could discover
um natural numbers even if there were no
other fingers around
by wrapping things you can wrap things
around several times and actually it's
much better because this wrapping in
some sense does more just these two
numbers
I
so you're saying a homotopic group is a
homotopic class is the number of
windings it's number windings and so but
actually C is much better so number one
these windings you could really see that
they are equal whereas if you have a a
bowl of strawberries it no two
strawberries are exactly the same right
so actually you may have a hard time
convincing a child that they should be
counted in the same progression in the
same sort of like uh process you see but
when you wrap things around it does look
like that it's just winding it's the
same and you also realize negative
numbers not only positive numbers
because you can also wind things in the
opposite direction and I've never seen
minus five strawberries you see so in
other words
i i i likewise you can also wrap a
sphere onto itself it is harder to
um to to find a prop for that
but mathematicians have a theory of
what's called homotopic groups it's
where it's mixture go one dimension
higher than the previous example and you
can also wrap a sphere onto itself
and you can wrap it in any positive
number of times or any negative number
of times so an advanced Solaris
intelligence would be would naturally be
led to this type of abstraction of
wrapping its own surface onto itself and
discover numbers as a as a winding
number as a as a number counting how
many times it perhaps on itself this
example illustrates the unity of
mathematics that the same concept can
arise from different
um
fields of mathematics in this case from
topology slash geometry and from number
theory of proper where you're actually
just counting things but the concept of
numbers is sort of on the intersection
of this and there are many other ways to
get to the Metro numbers it's like you
were saying earlier about Pi how
interesting that Pi appears is the ratio
of a spoken well that was bigger yeah I
can't take credit that was vigner so
like not me Eugene Wagner okay well
I'd love to take credit for bigness and
you can take and you can get also PI
from formulas for voting uh for
statistical distributions and also as I
mentioned although I I mispronounced the
the answer the sum of inverse squares is
pi squared over six you see so Pi
appears in in this variety of ways and
likewise every mathematical concept so
this actually is brings us to this idea
of language programs so I think for me
personally I was I've always been
interested in this idea of unity of how
you can get the same things from the
different parts of mathematics and so
language program is actually about that
yeah could you uh could you do the favor
of you know it's kind of like having uh
you know uh having a rock superstar like
uh like like having Mick Jagger here and
say don't you don't have to sing
Satisfaction you know don't worry about
that so come on you're the you're the
you're the foremost Master it's funny
it's funny you it's funny you mentioned
that because I just had a conversation
about exactly this song it was a friend
of mine was an artist
I keep saying you know can you imagine
Mick Jagger he's done it so many times
and he's still doing it like how often
you possibly do it so many times and I
said but he explains to you that he
can't get no satisfaction he gets the
satisfaction when he's singing the song
that's the whole point he's saying it
that's right I said it I I didn't know
where it came from it was kind of on the
inside which I just had at that moment
so you know it's kind of like this so I
get Satisfaction by explaining what
language program is about
I like Mick Jagger yeah right well thank
you for the comparison yeah
so well uh it's exactly like that so
it's like you get in natural numbers or
whole numbers in two different ways from
two different fields of mathematics so I
would call this a kind of a baby version
an example prototype or unifying
different parts of mathematics number
Theory anthropology but anthropology
would uh you know reference the general
idea of things like winding and wrapping
things on itself and so on
uh but in language program in that the
the original uh connection was between
the number Theory and what's called
harmonic analysis which is
basically you can you can appreciate it
by thinking about the sound of a
symphony uh playing a a piece of music
uh as being
um a kind of superposition
of different notes of different
instruments so different a note played
by a single instrument is what we call a
harmonic so it's a mathematically
represented by sine of cosine wave but
they have different frequency and when
you put them next good you combine them
you can actually create sounds a very
sophisticated sounds which are much more
assistive than the original sine and
cosine functions right so that's the
idea of harmonic analysis and so what
language
um
imagine or what he saw in some
manifestations and situations is that
some difficult problems so come of Not A
theater where you're basically counting
things like counting Solutions of some
complicated equations
polynomial equations
could be uh recast as a problem in
harmonic analysis where the answer could
be uh found in a much more
straightforward thing
so kind of much more easily solvable
problems so that was the original uh
formulation and you could say that the
way I talk about it like he established
a bridge between two continents of
mathematics number Theory and harmonic
analysis and there is a pattern so it's
not just a random connection but it's a
particular pattern where certain
structures arise
and then similar structures also
appeared in other areas of mathematics
like geometry
and
um
and the presentation Theory but then
also in quantum physics so in quantum
physics there is this idea of
electromagnetic duality
where amongst those equations in vacuum
they're just invariant under exchange
electrical magnetic fields even though
they have very different administations
in the physical world and uh if we try
to see if that holds in the quantum
world we would have to accept the
existence of what called Virat monopoles
the particles which carry magnetic
charge haven't been observed yet as far
as I know right now I have a video about
that I'll link to it above here we did a
video about the Valentine's Day event of
1982 uh collaborator at our friend at
Stanford Blas Cabrera uh claimed he
detected the monopole because direct
said you only need one monopole in the
whole universe to explain the value of
the quanta of the
elections such beautiful mathematical
argument
but but
um so interesting enough uh
electromagnetism is What's called the
gauge Theory so where the group uh
governing this gauge theory is called U1
it's a circle group the group of
rotations of a circle and uh but we know
that there are also Gage theories
corresponding to other groups for
instance the weak interaction weak force
is described by H theory in which the
group is called yes U2 so it's a group
of two by two Matrix the unitary Matrix
is returning to one and so on and the
strong strong interactions as you three
and so on and so if it's wondered in the
70s whether there is an analog of
electromagnetic duality
for those PhD areas and they found their
astonishment that if such a duality
existed and now I have to say that these
are not quite realistic models because
they are what's called supersymmetric
models with maximal super symmetry from
core Dimensions so they're not quite uh
don't quite correspond to the real world
but not too far kind of like micro
formulation is very similar to The
Realistic models what they discovered is
that if electromagnet duality
holds for such models then it would not
be between the model and itself but
between the model and the navigation in
which the group is another group which
actually turned out to be the last what
we call my princess language dual group
and that's one of the biggest mysteries
of the language correspondence is that
the Symmetry group it gets replaced by
this other group and then suddenly
physicists find the same phenomenon in
the electromagnetic Duality so that's a
kind of astonishing you know
surprise you know that first of all it
sort of cuts to several things that we
have discussed the connection between
mathematical discoveries and discoveries
in physics but also this Unity that
there's something phenomena which
appeared in many different branches of
mathematics and physics and to me that
signifies that there are higher levels
of understanding higher levels so
mathematicians you know in 100 years or
200 years will just look at things
differently they will see you know in a
way what we perceive now at different
fields of mathematics it's just like
different projections of this much more
multi-dimensional
um subject it's like you know if I take
this this cup and project it onto the
floor I will see a disk but if I project
it on the wall I will see a rectangle so
it's like number Theory
manifestations over the cup would be
like projection to the floor and we see
them as in a certain way and then you
know administrations in Geometry
analysis or microphysics would be
projections onto the wall but in fact
the subject itself isn't so much richer
and when we discover oh it's actually a
cup it is actually a a teacup and what
we were looking at before were the
projections there is projections the way
that's why this mysterious connections
they are no longer mysterious when we
see them manifested inside the cup yes
excellent well before we turn to the uh
to the existential questions I have one
more quote from uh Wegner he said
mathematics is the science of skillful
operations with Concepts and rules
invented just for this purpose the
principal emphasis is on the invention
of Concepts seems to me he's
definitively answering the Eternal
question of whether or not mathematics
is invented or discovered and I've asked
Steven strogatz I've asked Jim Simons I
want to ask you is math mathematics
invented or is it discovered
yes well I knew you were going to ask
this you know I I used to really think a
deep and hard about this
and but my understanding my feeling or
my intuition about it because obviously
there's no proof either way right maybe
there will be one day but we don't have
a proof today uh or either way so it's
more of a speculation it's more like
intuition my intuition of it has evolved
over the years I used to be squarely a
platonist
and when I say platonist is it me in
this in this context it means that uh
you believe that my colleges live
somewhere outside of space and time so
in 11 math I have I you know I sort of I
was sort of waxed or romantic about this
Enchanted Gardens you know number Theory
where everybody's Gala went and brought
us the flowers you know these color
groups and so on so I was really seduced
by this idea which I thought was very
romantic idea that there is something
outside of this world and that's why
because when you do mathematics as a
professional
uh you you get exposed to so many things
which unfortunately our math education
doesn't let most people to see and it
really looks so incredibly dazzling and
fascinating that it and not linked to
the to the physical world at our current
understanding right that you start it is
very natural and I would say most
mathematicians are closer to operators
they wouldn't tell you maybe directly
maybe they whisper if you know if you
are friends with them I do not tell you
directly because it sounds like it's
like a bad form to be like a Mystic you
know to right say something like that
but most people believe that that is the
case that there is something weird about
Mad Max it is not all of it not it's not
true that all of it comes from the
physical world around us but there is
something big beneath the surface okay
and I was very firmly in that camp
[Music]
but what I think now is a little bit
different so what I think is that
actually it's one of those cases
where there is not an objective answer
it depends on how you look at it so for
instance and to give you an analogy this
happens in quantum physics all the time
for instance you ask is an electron a
particle or a wave
and the answer is it's neither and both
in some sense right in other words if
you set up an experiment in one way it
will manifest itself as a particle if
you set up an experiment in another way
and this what I'm saying is something
very well known and very you know one
can Google it and find out exactly what
I mean that double State experiment if
you set it up in one way the electrons
will behave as particles if you set it
up with a detector behind the slave and
so on and if you set up in a different
way it will behave as a wave so what is
it a particle or a wave is this cup a
disc or or a rectangle an either it is
something else so if there is something
else it's beyond those those Concepts
and what we observe is that Heisenberg
said beautifully it's not nature itself
but nature exposed to our method of
questioning in other words the math
nature which we have put in a particular
context of our experimental protocol if
you will and this experimental protocol
can can be changed and the nature will
expose other sides and sometimes the
size it seem contradictory to us at this
moment of evolution where these things
seem to pass as contradictory in nature
but in fact for nature nature is more is
much more mystery than we know at the
moment in my opinion that from the point
of view of nature higher point which you
have not yet reached there is no
contradiction just like there is no
generation in the fact that the cup
projects onto a disc in one way projects
onto a rectangle in another way so same
for me today about the question it might
mess is invented or discovered it's like
electron if it's a particle or a wave it
depends on how you ask it depends on
from which angle you look it is like
more complementary principle the two
properties seem to be complementary but
I think it's both the SML in other words
there's some elements of Badness which
where they discovered
but if you look at it in a certain way
if you look another way it is invented
by humans but who are humans anyway who
are we who are we who are who are you
Brian yes do you know who you are yes
exactly the point is in the year to me
it actually leads to and this is where I
I'm not being facetious I'm actually
being serious these questions are useful
this question about is my life
discovered or invented and so on they're
useful just like a question is a human
being a robot a thinking machine and so
there's nothing but a sequence of zeros
and ones or a human is a human being a
collection of particles and nothing else
and and I know that many of our
colleagues very brilliant ones who
subscribe to these ideas but what I'm
I'm not trying to say they are correct
or they're not correct right or wrong
but what it reveals is what they think
about who they are so all questions
ultimate all questions of that nature we
can call it metaphysical questions we
can call it philosophical questions or
whatever they well we have to appreciate
that they are they it's there is a
review when one speaks about it a review
is that in fact it leads they all lead
to one questions like all roads lead to
Rome and that question is who Am I who
am I if I think that I am a sequence of
zeros and once then I will believe that
the world is computer simulation on
somebody's computer and so on and then I
will believe that uh something else
about what the mathematics discovered or
invented and if I do if I think of
something else then I would so you see
them so these discussions are very
important but I think at some times we
have to also make the next step and
actually ask the question directly
which my friend uh
by the way speaking of the cover of my
book oh yeah himself yes he wrote he
gave me a beautiful blur
that if you are not a mathematician this
book might make you want to become one
she calls skill in the game okay so it's
all fun and games when you just talk
about things abstractly which we are
used to in some ways as scientists we
pretend that we're talking about the
physical world but these electrons are
weird and so on but nothing has nothing
to do with me you know so that's like no
skin in the game you're just you're
you're removing yourself from your from
your world and Quantum actually to me
shows that you can that's the whole
point that's what Heisenberg meant when
he said what we are observing is not
nature itself but nature exposed to our
uh way uh method of questioning it or
mental observation you're always
involved as an observer quantum physics
proves it okay so that skin in the game
so let's have skin at the game and let's
ask those questions too and I know
you're asking me now so that's why I'm
giving you the sense and maybe on that
last uh topic before we wrap up with the
existential questions
um when we here in physics that there's
only a few years left before we have
artificial intelligent physicists
artificial Galileo galile AIO or
artificial Einstein a-i-a-e but I always
like to point out that good old you know
Albert Einstein he uh he had a very
famous quote on his on his most famous
discovery which was that uh which he
called the happiest thought of his life
which was that if an observer was in
free fall they would experience no
gravitational acceleration equivalence
equivalence but it's exactly but I want
to ask you Edward how can how can an
artificial intelligent computer a have a
happiest thought what does that even
mean and B how could they relate to the
physical visceral sensation of falling
It seems impossible to me but I want to
ask you in the context of mathematics is
there mathematics I know that there's
obviously lots of Chess and and so forth
but I'm actually not as interested in
you know whether or not computers can
beat humans at chess I want to know Shak
mati all right uh but I want to know can
a computer invent a game like chess I
don't seem to feel like that's possible
but I want to know what you think
right that's exactly the kind of thing
I'm talking about so and that's one of
the questions which leads to the
question who am I right so that
who am I do I believe that everything in
my life
is programmed so numbers can be ascribed
to intelligence to logical thinking or
do I believe that there are things in my
life which go beyond logic you know
bless Pascal no less was a very smart
guy
and he was a great scientist and
mathematician he said the heart has its
reasons of which the reason knows
nothing that's right the heart has its
reasons of which the reason knows
nothing and all the great ones they knew
about it that's how they felt and you
could say oh Pascal was a long time ago
so he was a religious man perhaps of
Einstein is on record saying the most
important thing in science is the
mysterious and I'm paraphrasing the one
who doesn't see it has their eyes closed
you know and so they're not really doing
which you open something but not just
mentioned in Hillsborough Heisenberg I
have already quoted and so on so these
guys knew that there are other
dimensions in life other than thinking
call it intuition imagination which by
the way Einstein said imagination is
more important than knowledge and so on
except if you go to the dentist uh
Edward you know you go to the dentist
you want to have some knowledge or her
to have some knowledge not but see
there's this creative thing on your
teeth here here's what Edward Franklin
adds to this this course okay so here's
a thought experiment let's suppose uh
sometimes I use it when I ask is
concussion so maybe I'll close with that
let's suppose that AI today at Christian
tells you whatever you call it computers
whatever you know computer neural
networks which by the way oh my God you
will not resolve every problem really
and it's based on 19th century
mathematics what about the 20th century
Market 21st century mathematics doesn't
sound sound a little odd but none of
that is useful come on but let's suppose
that neural networks AI machine learning
whatever you want to call it today can
cover 99 of all Human Experience let's
suppose
ask yourself this
excuse me ask yourself this what is more
important to you this 99 or the one
remaining one yes ask yourself this and
well where I stand on this probably is
clear from what I said earlier yes uh
most interesting part in life is that
which is not captured right now to get
to that you may actually
have to do a live computation but there
is a moment of oh there is a moment of
inside there is a moment of when you
reach the peak and and you see the
beautiful Valley which is opening in
front of you
does it is it covered by 99 or one
percent and so on so I believe that we
will progress and we will Maybe cover
more and in ways which we cannot now
imagine computation a logic reason is
one of the basic major human impulses
and wonderful look how much great stuff
we can do with it and obviously the
professional mathematician that's that's
what I do for a living where we go
straight
is when we say there is nothing to life
but computation there is nothing like
but thinking and so we should just do
more thinking and then we will solve our
problems well first of all the history
of authorization shows that's not the
case because even if you are so thinking
maybe other people don't I'm not
subscribing to that number one but is it
everything in your life based on
thinking really you really always make
decisions based on thinking well
congratulations I'm glad you do but I
have some serious doubts about it and if
you are honest with yourself maybe you
will remember a moment or two when your
emotions took over when your intuition
over overriding your thinking and so on
so when we go straight is when we say
there is nothing else bad competition
there is nothing else but thinking and
so on the great ones knew that the heart
has its reasons of which the reason
knows nothing and I think that we have
to take some uh wisdom from that and
take it seriously and then you know
that's the balance and that's the
balance yeah
that's the balance between love and math
right right there all right I want to
ask you one rapid question and one uh
and then one longer question just to
finish up for a minute response but the
one uh single word answer I'm gonna ask
you now Edward you ready love or math
choose one
well and then in the next breath I say
don't have don't choose one over the
other because we go astray also if we go
too far on the other side I've seen
people do that too and I don't want uh
to do that
you know I have a website which can
sometimes you can see it on the internet
folks you can see a chunky mathematician
named Edward Franks
so what I am uh but my practice is in
some sense is uh or what my goal in life
is to find the balance between the two I
think I today we spoke I spoke more
about the dangers of being imbalanced or
going too far on the side of my but I
have to say that the same is true if you
go too far on the other side also and
sometimes you know we play so we can go
sometimes we go get ahead of ourselves
go too far but we have to remember and
come back and I think that's where we
are at our best as human beings as
individuals and as a society when we are
both because you know we're best when we
use both hands not just one but both you
see and so think of this as love and
think of this as math and so you know
Bond them together when we do both you
know well yeah I can't think of anyone
else who's more uh superlative at doing
that and communicating it and doing the
most uh far-reaching research that the
mind can even grasp I mean just to go
through uh some of your research in
preparation it's it's just so
fascinating Edward I hope we can meet in
person I I've never met in person we're
in the same University system next time
I come up to Berkeley uh I will stop by
to see you my friend uh for now I want
to thank you so much for going into the
impossible
thank you it was a lot of fun any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
thank you
[Music]